[Music]
matt is in washington dc hi
matt welcome to the show hey dave and
anthony thanks so much for taking my
call really appreciate it
sure what's up hey question so
i don't know if i'm overthinking this or
not but so i'm 25 years old and i just
moved to dc to be closer to my
girlfriend
and we broke up and so i'm thinking
about buying a motorcycle
for about five grand i don't know if i
can afford it or not
i make 120 grand a year i've got about
150 grand cash
just in the bank and i've got another
100 grand just sitting in
50 grand in single stocks under 50 grand
that's 401k
you're kidding i do oh you've got all of
that and you're calling us about a five
thousand dollar purchase
what's really going on six thousand i
say it again i'm sorry i said what's
really going on here how much is the
motorcycle
five thousand dollars well i also got
146 000
in debt oh we'll write a check and pay
all that off and then we'll have a
discussion about a motorcycle
and then buy the bike yeah could i i
don't exactly
i have two investment properties i rent
where i live and i have a 24 grand on a
car
but i don't know if i'm overthinking it
or not but i guess if you know i don't
know i guess you're saying maybe i am
overthinking it
one percent of your life worries is a
five thousand dollar motorcycle
ninety-nine percent of your life worth
is 146 thousand dollars in debt yeah
got it write a check and pay off the
debt go buy the motorcycle are you
buying a motorcycle because you're
grieving over the girlfriend
yeah yeah a little bit yeah i want
something to do i mean i thought my
weekends would be with her and now i'm
you know we're not together so i just
want to go out and make friends and just
kind of have stuff to do you know
you can make friends without a
motorcycle man
[Laughter]
why do you need a motorcycle to make
friends
you know yeah the only down the only
negative part about the motorcycle is
number one the debts in the way number
two it sounds like it might be some
grief
spending grieving over the relationship
right and
um not that it's because it's not gonna
kill you financially you can afford
to buy the bike yeah you could afford to
buy the bike and set
fire to it in the driveway and not worry
about it it's not gonna kill you
financially
but what you can't afford is to get into
a situation where
you react to uh bad feelings in your
life
by spending yes you can't you can't put
that groove in your brain
that that groove will destroy you long
term yeah it definitely will definitely
will and and and hear me clearly man
when you pay off this debt i want you to
go ahead and get your emergency fund
back up because i got to give it to you
to have that kind of money at this age
that's that's great you're just doing a
little bit backwards from what we teach
you know so go ahead and pause all your
investments right now
uh because i want you to go ahead and
get out of the debt and then make sure
you get your three to six months i think
he's got enough to do that he probably
just
needs to allocate it it sounds like
there's a couple hundred grand if i
understood right well there's 150
000 in the savings and a hundred
thousand in investments yeah
so use some of both let's use all the
savings yes you're 146 000 you're paid
off at least four thousand dollars right
okay pull some out of investments and
make sure it's set aside as an emergency
fund
and buy the bike cool great and you get
all three done then you've got your
first three baby steps
we call them in place matt but just just
search your own soul and look in the
mirror and go dude
is this just am i just grief spending
here yeah
um and that's not something you want to
get into is a long-term
thing that every time i feel bad i spend
every time i feel bad i
eat those kinds of things you know what
dave this is why we teach
don't move until you are married don't
make a life-changing move because he
said he moved to this place for his
girlfriend
i mean that's a that's a different
subject i mean we own the dave ramsey
show
hey it's anthony o'neill show whatever
y'all go with me so i'll go with me so
don't you're saying don't chase girls
and boys around the country don't do it
and not unless you not unless you are
married
like why move to the city hardcore why
move in with the person
you are hardcore i mean what dave okay i
didn't say i'm not saying on that but
yeah
but i mean chasing somebody you know
moving to the city with the person
yeah versus moving in no i didn't say
moving in
so you into the city of the house oh
yeah see i still i'm st
if my daughter came home and said i'm
moving to another city so i can be
closer to my boyfriend i will have a
problem with that
yeah i mean it's not wrong i'm just
saying
you're up and rooting your whole life
for the possibility of this thing to
work out
i think i'd want some circumstances
listed out around that
before i would make that call okay if it
sounded like immature and flighty and
like she was being used up or
manipulated definitely
but if she's a strong woman make her own
calls
that's a different issue